l'objectif de ces travaux est de
comprendre comment les oiseaux compose
avec les plantations d'épinettes dans
leurs déplacements soient pas tacher la
trashy ce succès fait on fait des
expériences très spécifique pour
vérifier effectivement que ce qui
arriverait dans un scénario où on
continue d'intensifier par exemple ici
on est dans une plantation qui entoure
certaines parcelles de forêt feuillue
sont de l'habitat propice pour nous est
ce possible la paruline couronner la
paix revienne à gorge noir
on a voulu voir si le fait de capturer
ces oiseaux là et de les déplacer à 25km
influence est premièrement leur capacité
de revenir à leur site par ce qui est
entouré plantation est aussi influencé
la capacité de d'autres individus de
venir remplacer ce qu'on avait déplacé